actuellement les or on est en pleine mer
au large de l'embouchure de la rivière
des galets au début la baie de saint
paul la côté nord
on est sur la deuxième journée de la
coupe de la réunion de voile c'est la
deuxième épreuve de référence à la
réunion pour la saison 2015 et c'est la
dernière épreuve de la sélection aux
jeux des îles
aurait il est 14h46 son renvoi le
pavillon euros il y en a quatre minutes
un programme qui se compose de va se
composer là pour cette coupe de 7 cette
course chaque course étant constituée
d'un départ qui se passe entre notre
bateau est une bouée qui est à notre
gauche et ensuite les concurrents
doivent remonter vers la direction d'où
vient le vent pour contourner une
première bouée puis une seconde et ils
font un nombre de tours ont fait varier
pour que la course dure entre 40 minutes
et une heure
le niveau est quoi la locale régionale
nationale
gagner la course et relationnelles
on a des séries ont sectionné 96 du
radial c'est 2
en or de wels différente avec le même
support par contre on garde la même
coque est effectivement on a des
gabarits un peu plus important sur les
voiles de radiall et gabarit plus léger
donc nos jeunes qui sont sûres sur de
4.7
il faut analyser si le bateau s'arrête
pas dans les vagues 6
si la voile
reste toujours bien gonflés et si le
bateau
c'est toujours une bonne vitesse est
également au niveau tactique souvent les
personnes
s'ils font les bons choix sur le plan
d'eau c'est tout
il ira
il vient d'ailleurs d'être
des applis dans un pôle espoir à la
rochelle la pop
il est en tête et va normalement là on
n'est qu'à 10 sur la sur ce bord tout le
tapage
au premier à remonter j'ai pas pris la
bonne option
et ouais c'est aux portois que ça allait
vraiment jouer quoi
mais c'est le doigt là il y en a
d'autres mais bon sang pourquoi c'est
aussi content parce que c'est la
dernière
ouais y'a la manche d'avant je suis
complètement loupé qui vont du coup j'ai
rattrapé quoi ça leur physique
ouais c'est pas facile on a deux
instruments fournis par semaine pour
procès de compenser le manque pour la
part longueuil